vous inquiétez pas les symptômes de la
ménopause sont très proches de ceux des
grossesses date une r non
tu vas pas me la faire à chaque fois
cela qui me prend pour une [ __ ] ou quoi
ah non qu'est ce que c'est que ces
bambins pendant un tournage franchement
comme ça c'est un corps et jean-pierre
pensons pas qu'il m'a mise à l'aise
ensemble ma personne saverne
te voilà de nouveau habité un peu près
d'un petit locataires qui loge dans son
emballage également aux squatteurs en
fait jean pierre j'ai bien réfléchi
elle est trop vieux pour sa voiture
s'imagine j'ai déjà du mal à baisser
pour ramasser les chaussettes
enfin je te rassure tu n'as jamais fait
un 50 alors que ça change ici ça fait 40
ans est une fille chez jean
ça fait deux ans tournage c'est plus un
break c'est un renoncement des dizaines
de fois sur l'autoroute ça me fait pas
bander te demande pas de bande et
jean-pierre demande de travailler
je crois que c'est par hasard si ça nous
arrive cela maintenant tu comprends tu
mens pas assez une fois
enfin nicole m'était complètement
inconsciente et a fait du bien
bah tu verras proprio c'est pas un
cadeau